some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want
success is a feeling it's not a it's not
a series of check marks and goals
i think people define success as as
finish lines
as social animals our success our
happiness our joy our ability to get
anything
done requires help need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe nation
top 10.
all my life
he's simon sinek and here's my take on
his top 50 rules for success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one break the rules
let me tell you a story so a friend of
mine and i
we went for a run in central park the
roadrunners organization
uh on the weekends they host races
and it's very common at the end of the
race they'll have a sponsor who will
give away
something apples or bagels or something
and on
this particular day when we got to the
end of the run there were some free
bagels
and they had picnic tables set up and on
one side was a group of volunteers
on the table were boxes of bagels and on
the other side
was a long line of runners waiting to
get their free bagel
so i said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel and he looked at me and said
ah the line's too long and i said
free bagel and he said i don't want to
wait
in line and i was like
free bagel and he says nah
let's it's too long and that's when i
realized
that there's two ways to see the world
some people
see the thing that they want and some
people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want
i could only see the bagels he could
only see the line
and so i walked up to the line
i leaned in between two people
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels
and no one got mad at me because the
rule is
you can go after whatever you want you
just cannot deny
anyone else to go after whatever they
want
now i had to sacrifice choice i didn't
get to choose which bagel i got i got
whatever i pulled out
but i didn't have to wait in line so the
point is is you don't have to wait in
line
you don't have to do it the way
everybody else has done it you can do it
your way
you can break the rules you just can't
get in the way of somebody else
getting what they want that's rule
number one rule number two
train your mind performing under
pressure whether it's me or anybody else
is the same
you know i have the same pressures as
anyone else there's time there's
performance there's financial i mean
there are you know there's deadlines my
pressures are not unique
um the situations may be different or
you know but but
everybody has the same kinds of
pressures um
but what i found or what i find
fascinating is the interpretation of the
stimuli
if let me let me explain so i was
watching the olympics this last summer
olympics
and i was amazed at how bad the
questions were that the reporters would
ask
all the athletes and almost always they
asked the same question
whether they were about to compete or
after they competed
were you nervous right and
to a t all the athletes went no
right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean what happens when
you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right
you have expectation of what's coming
and we interpreted that as i'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes
have learned to interpret the stimuli
that the rest of us would say as
nervous as excited they all say the same
thing no i'm not nervous
i'm excited and so i've actually
practiced it
just to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement
yeah you know and so where when you i
used to speak in front of a large
audience and somebody would say how do
you feel i just say
a little nervous now when somebody says
how do you feel i'm like
really excited actually and it it came
from just sort of
telling myself no no this is excitement
and it becomes a little bit automatic
later on um but it's kind of a
remarkable thing to deal with pressure
by interpreting
what your body is experiencing as
excitement rather than
nerves and it's really kind of effective
it makes you want to rush forward rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience
rule number three be patient i talk to
so many
smart fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids
and they're right out of college they're
in their entry level jobs and i'll ask
them
how's it going and they'll say i think
i'm going to quit
and i'm like why they say to me i'm not
making an impact
i'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love
like it's a scavenger hunt like it's
something you look for
my millennial friends they've gone
through so many jobs they're either
getting fired
i mean it was mutual
or they're quitting because they're not
making an impact or they're not finding
the thing they're looking for they're
not feeling fulfilled as if it's a
scavenger hunt
love a job you
find joy from is not something you
discover
it's not like i found love here it is
i found a job i love that's not how it
works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work
very hard every single day of your life
to stay
in love you find a job that brings you
ultimate joy because you work hard every
single day
to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy
it's not a discovery but the problem is
the sense of impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain
they know exactly what they want they
can see the summit what they can't see
is the mountain
this large immovable object
that doesn't mean you have to do your
time that's not what i'm talking about
take a helicopter climb i don't care but
there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is this entire generation
has an institutionalized sense of
impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next
dump and on to the next ghost and on to
the next
rule number four take accountability in
the
18th century there was something
that spread across europe and eventually
made its way to america called
puerto fever also known as the black
death of child bed basically what was
happening
is women were giving birth and
they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of europe
and it got worse and worse and worse
over the course
of over a century in some hospitals
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth
who would die as a result of giving
birth but this was the renaissance
this was the time of empirical data and
science and we had thrown away things
like tradition and mysticism
these were men of science these were
doctors and these doctors and men of
science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work
studying and they would study the
corpses
of the of the women who had died and in
the morning they would conduct autopsies
and then in the afternoon they would go
and deliver babies and finish their
rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice
oliver wendell holmes realized that all
of these doctors were conducting
autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies
in the afternoon and he pointed it out
and said guys
you're the problem and they ignored him
and called him crazy for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands
it would go away and that's exactly what
happened
when they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands
the black death of childbed disappeared
my point is the lesson here is sometimes
you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new
men of science and empirical uh studiers
and these men of finance
who are smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions
you can take all the credit in the world
for the things that you do right
as long as you also take responsibility
for the things you do wrong it must be a
balanced equation
you don't get it one way and not the
other you get to take credit
when you also take accountability also
if you want to learn how to build more
confidence check out my 254 series it's
free the link is in the description
below
but i'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself and even though i'm going to
sell you the most beautiful hammer
i'm not going to guarantee the
structural integrity of the house rule
number five
outdo yourself i spoke at an education
summit for microsoft i also spoke at an
education summit for
apple at the education for my at the
education summit for microsoft
i would say that 70 of the executives
spent about 70 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat
apple at the apple education summit
a hundred percent of the executives
spent a hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite and the other one
is playing infinite gets which one gets
frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface
was incredible the design was
spectacular
i absolutely loved it it was easy to use
and it was
bright and gorgeous and fanta it didn't
work on itunes which is a different
problem
so i couldn't use it but but it was
amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant so i'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior apple executive sort of
employee number 12 kind of guy
and you know i like to stir pots so i
turned him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better than your ipod
touch
and he turned to me and he said i have
no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse the goal isn't to
be the best
every day the goal isn't to out to outdo
your competition
every day that's a finite construction
if i had said to microsoft i've got the
new ipod touch and it's so much better
than your zoom
they would have said can we see it what
does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play to be better than
themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today
than it was yesterday how can we create
a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we
also have to play the infinite game it's
not about being ranked number one
it's not about having more followers on
twitter than your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself it's not about selling more
books or getting more ted views
than somebody else it's about how to
make sure that the work that you're
producing
is better than the work you produced
before
you are your competition and that is
what ensures you stay
in the game the longest and that is what
ensures you find
joy because the joy comes
not from comparison but from advancement
rule number six stack the deck when are
you at your best
i'm at my best when i'm around people
who believe what i believe
i know it seems silly but um
i try very very hard to sort of stack
the deck you know to put myself in a
position of strength
um so for example you know somebody
asked me just yesterday have you ever
had sort of a bad
you know engagement i was thinking
myself i'm like not really but it's not
because i'm
some sort of sort of genius
understanding anything like that
it's because i stack the deck it's
because i want to be there
i want to be around people who want me
there in other words if i'm somebody's
tenth choice
and like you know i'll probably turn it
down
whereas if i'm their first choice they
really want me there and so i'm more
likely to have a good engagement they're
supportive of me i'm supportive of them
and so um yeah i'm at my best when i
when i stack the deck when i choose to
be in an environment where
my strengths are are there rule number
seven
be the last to speak nelson mandela is
a particularly special case study in the
leadership world
because he is universally regarded as a
great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but nelson mandela
across the world is universally regarded
as a great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day how did you
learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings and he remembers two
things
when his father would meet with other
elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two his father was always
the last to speak you will be told your
whole life that you need to learn to
listen
i would say that you need to learn to be
the last to speak
i see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders
will walk into a room and say here's the
problem here's what i think but i'm
interested in your opinion let's go
around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself until everyone has
spoken
does two things one it gives everybody
else the feeling
that they have been heard it gives
everyone else the ability to
feel that they have contributed and two
you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself
if you agree with somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean
and why they have the opinion that they
have you must understand
from where they are speaking why they
have the opinion they have
not just what they are saying and at the
end
you will get your turn it sounds
easy it's not practice being the last to
speak
that's what nelson mandela did rule
number eight
be authentic every decision we make in
our lives as
individuals or as organizations is a
piece of communication
it's our way of saying something about
who we are and what we believe
this is why authenticity matters this is
why you have to say
and do the things you actually believe
because the things you say and do are
symbols
of who you are and we look for those
symbols so we can find people who
believe what we believe
our very survival depends on it so if
you're putting out false symbols
you will attract people to those symbols
but you won't be able to form
trust with them this is what tiger woods
did to us
he lied he lied he told
us what he thought we wanted to hear and
it was great
and we were drawn to it and all of us
who kind of liked that idea of the
sort of the good guy we're drawn to it
until we found out it was a lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great
athletes of our day but he didn't he
chose to lie
good luck forming trust again tiger we
don't believe you
we don't trust you the goal of putting
something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe
what you believe if you go to one of
your friends
and you say to one of your friends how
would you like me to dress
so that you'll like me better how would
you want me to address you how do you
want me to
speak so that you'll like me more
right your friends are going to look at
you be like what are you talking about
come on come on come on what should i
wear so that you'll find me more
appealing
and how would you like me to speak to
you so that you like me more
and your friends are going to tell you
just be yourself
that's why i like you i don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
industry
what do we do we do market research and
we go and we ask the customers
what kind of things the way we what
style should we speak to you how should
we decorate ourselves what kind of
things are you drawn to so that we can
do those things so you'll like us more
it's just as ridiculous
it's just as ridiculous organizations
should say and do the things they
actually believe
and they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie
and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying
cynicism sets in and people start saying
i'm not sure i can trust
these guys because there's not a lot of
consistency in all the things they say
and do
which means they can't have a very
strong belief set or they're lying to me
and we call them inauthentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be
is inauthentic that's hilarious to me
all these positioning studies we do
are inherent we're going to do a study
to find out from people so we can be
more authentic
that's hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there
the things you say and the things you do
those red hats are ways that people can
find you
what you have the ability to do as
designers
is create those symbols and allow people
to use those things
to say something about who they are work
for companies work for clients
work for people who you believe what
they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part is to put what they
believe
into pictures and words and symbols and
graphics
so that other people can use those
things to say something about who they
are
people put harley davidson logos on
their body to say something about who
they are
corporate logo ain't no proctor and
gambles tattooed on anybody's arm
because harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on there not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle
they put that tattoo there to tell you
something about themselves
you ever see anybody with a with a mac
laptop put a sticker over that beautiful
shining apple
ain't never gonna happen then how will
you know who i am
do you ever see anybody with a pc break
out the windex to clean out their
computer
mac people
have you ever seen a dirty mac doesn't
exist
does not exist why because it's who i am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe and they're disciplined in how
they do it and they're consistent what
they do and everything they say
and everything they do serves as a
symbol of the set of values and beliefs
we use
those symbols to say something about who
we are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about who
we are and when we can find the people
who believe what we believe
we're weirdly drawn to them because our
very survival
depends on it we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can
discipline with discipline say in blue
and do the things you actually believe
strange things start to happen
rule number nine find your passion what
are your thoughts and what's your
approach
on finding and building upon passions
passion is not an actionable word it's
correct
you know that those who do the things
that they're passionate about do better
but
it's not helpful advice and so the
question is where does passion come from
passion is a result passion is an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something
that you love passion is the feeling you
have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know
and i think we mistake that passion is
something we do in our private lives but
it shouldn't be done
you know in our careers for example and
i'm a firm believer that you are who you
are
and anybody who says i'm different at
home than i am at work and one of those
two places you're lying
and the goal is to make everything you
do in
home and at work something that you have
excitement to do
so how do you find the things that
you're excited to do well it's actually
easier than you think what are the
things that you love to do what are the
things that
you would do for free you know how can
you recreate that feeling
and and be paid for it so what are the
things that i do on the weekend right
i love um i'm very involved in the art
world
i love to go to museums and galleries
but i love to go see
dance and performances because i want to
see how others are
interpreting the world so that inspires
me new ideas new thoughts new ways of
looking at the world
are things that interest me privately
and i seek it out and pay money for it
right so does that mean i have to have a
career in the arts
no it means i have to have a career
where new ideas are explored
where people are experimenting and
trying things out
and i have to explore new ideas and try
things out and i'm just as excited to go
to work every day as i am to
you know go do something on a saturday
night um and so
the idea of finding your passion is
ironically simple because
you should be doing stuff that you enjoy
sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love
who are the people that you love and
what are those what they all have in
common rule number 10
start with why rule number 11
pursue your vision people are always
talking about visions and missions and
all this stuff
um and um when people ask me like what
example should i look to
like what company should i'm like here's
an organization
with a vision a cause it was founded
with a cause
it's an entrepreneurial venture it's
america is an experiment it's an
entrepreneurial venture
where a bunch of people got together and
decided we needed to
start our own country um um
because there were certain obstacles
that were getting in the way of a vision
that we had of a better kind of country
but a kind of company right
and they stated it right out of the
beginning all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
and much amongst which include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and it's not a uh it's not just um a
competitive statement
like to be the best to be the most
respected that's not what it was
and i'm amazed how many companies start
their visions or missions
with those that terribly egocentric
language
it was an ideal and the amazing thing is
is we've been good at it and bad at it
in our history but
it's endured for 240 plus years
because we fundamentally believe that we
are at our best when we're pursuing that
but it isn't ideal
we will never actually achieve all
people are equal
but we will die trying and that's the
point
and it's the same for a company which is
true vision inside a company
is something that has nothing to do with
your product it is an ideal
to which you will attempt to build and
advance that ideal through your company
with your product
you'll never achieve the ideal but
you'll die trying and this is what gives
our work meaning this is what it gives
our lives purpose
right the difference between vision and
a goal is the finish line
a goal is 26.2 miles you can simply
count the metrics
and know when you've completed your goal
is a vision
is having a crystal clear sense of what
the finish line looks like but no idea
of how far away it is wow
and it's and the reality is you will
spend your entire
life never actually crossing the finish
line but the joy that every marathon you
complete you feel like you're getting
closer
every milestone that you accomplish
makes you feel like you're getting
closer and closer to the ideal
and this is what gives our life and our
work meaning rule number 12
measure momentum success is an elusive
thing right um
what is it and i think it's very
interesting that if most people can't
define success well it means you made x
amount of dollars
or but if you make x amount of dollars
but you spend more
are you successful or well it means you
come home happy every day
okay how do you know when you're happy
you know uh
so i think success is a funny thing
which is we all seem to pursue it
but we don't know how to measure it or
actually how to define it
so how do you pursue something that you
can't measure fascinating
um so when people say to me how do you
measure success the question we all have
to ask ourselves am i successful
i don't know i mean i had a good year
last year
uh and what does that mean does that
mean i made a lot of money does that
mean i was really happy oh i'll let you
decide right
right um maybe neither maybe both um
i had a good year last year but am i
successful and the answer is no
i don't feel i am because i'm trying to
build a world that doesn't exist yet
i'm trying to build a world in which 90
of people go home at the end of the day
feeling fulfilled by the work that they
do
so i definitely took a step a big step
forward towards that goal but i'm still
so far away
so somebody said to me then how do you
know if you're successful and the answer
is
if it can go by itself and so what is
more interesting to me
as a measurement of success is not the
the the markers per se
it's not the the financial goal or the
the size of the house that you want to
buy those are nice things go for it
those are
but those are not measurements of
success those are just nice things to
collect along the way
um for me it's momentum i want to
measure momentum which is
you know when when something is moving
and you start to see it lose momentum
you're like oh
give it a push because if you don't give
it push it's going to stop and an object
in stasis is much harder to get going it
requires a lot more energy
to get something started than it does to
keep it going right and so
if you don't let it stop and you can
keep it going it's this you know it
still might slow down down there but you
can get it going again much easier
and for me the opportunity is to get the
ball rolling faster and faster and
faster and faster and faster and bigger
and bigger and bigger it's like a
snowball
and my responsibility is because it's
not rolling downhill yet it's not on
automatic yet
i need to still keep it going to find
that critical mass where it can go
and at the point it can go by itself
without me then i will find something
else to do
and that may not happen in my lifetime i
think we must all stop measuring
promotions salaries and these things but
rather measure the momentum of your
career
does my career have momentum can i see
it moving in the right direction can i
see it gathering
moss you know can i see that it's easy
becoming easier for me
to keep the momentum it's becoming
easier for me to grow the size of this
thing it's it's requiring less effort
that's the thing we need to measure
that's the thing that we need to be
cognizant of which is the momentum of
our careers not just
the markers that we think define our
success rule number 13
be a giver i did a little experiment
with um
um with a homeless person not like on
them it's not like electrodes
with them voluntarily um helped me
um because the whole idea of giving
right you've you've all walked down the
street and you've all seen someone
begging and you either have or haven't
thrown a few pennies in their cup when
you do
you feel good you bought that feeling
that is a legitimate commercial
transaction
you know commercial transactions are
defined as the exchange of consideration
there was an exchange of consideration
here you gave money
you got the feeling of goodwill you paid
for that feeling
if you didn't give money you either feel
nothing
or you feel bad you can't feel good
by not giving all right you paid for
that feeling
so now the question is how is that
person encouraging us to give
the joke is they act like every
corporation in the world
they talk about themselves me me me
me me me right like they sit there with
their little outdoor advertising
little sign right and it says
i'm homeless i'm hungry i got 12 kids
i'm a veteran god bless they got it all
in there trying to appeal to somebody
the religious vote
the veteran vote you know the child
sympathizer
surround yourself with lots of pets go
for that one too right
all in an attempt to get something from
someone
takers not givers right all about me
well what do corporations do we've added
more ram we've added more rom we've
added more speed
this one's number one we're the biggest
we're the best we've been around since
1969.
we're better than them we're faster than
them we're more efficient than that one
me me me
me me me me me me and so even if we buy
their product guess what
yeah we don't really feel much so i did
this little experiment i found um
a nice homeless lady on the streets of
new york was willing to help out
and i learned that with her sign which
was pretty typical i'm homeless i'm
hungry
she makes between 20 and 30 dollars a
day
uh for you know for a day's worth of
work eight to ten hours of sitting there
selling goodwill
eight to ten hours she'll make twenty to
thirty dollars thirty dollars is
considered a good
day i changed her sign and the new sign
made her 40 dollars in two hours
and then she left
[Music]
it's one of the reasons she's homeless
is because she's decided that she only
needs twenty to thirty dollars a day to
live
if she stayed she would have made 150
dollars the point is she made 40 bucks
in two
hours what did the signs say the sign
said
if you only give once a month please
think of me next time
it has nothing to do with the taker it
has everything to do with the giver
and what are the objections people give
when they don't
give i can't give to everyone
how do i know that they really need it
and so i address both those concerns i
know you can't give to everyone so if
you only give once a month
my cause is legitimate i will still be
here when you're ready to give
40 bucks two hours make it about them
not about you
the fact of the matter is 100
of customers are people and 100
of clients are people and 100
of employees are people i don't care how
good your product is i don't care how
good your marketing is
i don't care how good your design is if
you don't understand people you don't
understand
business we are social animals we are
human beings
and our survival depends on our ability
to form
trusting relationships do you ever watch
um
uh deadliest catch on the discovery
channel
i was looking through channels one night
and deadliest catch came on and on this
episode
just random um they were in a huge storm
now for those of you who don't know
deadliest catch
they take these crab fishing boats out
in the bering sea which is like
terrible and they put cameras on them
and we watch right
the reason that's i guess significant is
because these crab fishermen have i
think
one of the top five deadliest jobs in
the world
you know i don't know what the exact
number is but dozens of
fishermen die every year doing doing
this
we apparently find that entertaining
which it actually is
so they have cameras only on five or six
of the ships even though there are many
many ships that go out
fishing every season and they don't
really come into proximity with each
other
because you know the ocean's huge and
they usually sabotage each other and
give each other false information
because they're all competitors they're
all looking to
get the crabs and you know make sure
that they find them somebody else
doesn't and yeah it's business right
it's just business it's okay
we all do the same thing in our own
companies and in this one episode this
big huge storm was so violent that they
had to bring all the pots which are the
big cages that they catch the crabs and
they had to bring all the parts back on
the boat and wait out the storm and just
by
dumb luck one of the boats that had
cameras on it
was in proximity of a boat that didn't
have cameras on it and so they filmed
they had secured all their pots on the
deck and so they started filming
the other boat and they filmed a guy
climbing on the outside of the cage
securing
the pots and all of a sudden a huge wave
hits the side of the boat and the guy's
not there anymore
and the people on the boat with the
cameras start screaming man overboard
man overboard man overboard
and they turn their boat towards
where they think he might be he's a
stranger they don't know him they don't
know the
the crew members of the other boat and
yet they react
and they turn towards him and they find
him in the drink
and for those of you don't understand
how dangerous this is if the water is so
cold that if you're in the water for i
think that it's a minute or a minute 30
hypothermia will set and then you die
and
they come upon him and he's screaming
don't let me die don't let me die
and they pull him on board not out of
the woods yet they strip off his clothes
because it's wet and cold and they wrap
blankets around him to prevent
hypothermia from setting in
and he survives and it's overwhelming
and the captain comes down
and this is all i mean you can go watch
it on tv the camera comes
the captain comes down and he hugs this
stranger
this young man his competitor he hugs
this guy as if
he's his own son i
i lost it everybody is crying
and you realize what happened here was a
human
interaction and the reason they risk
their own lives to help this other
person even though they spend every
other day trying to
get ahead in sabotage is because at the
end of the day they're all crab
fishermen
and they know something about each other
and they know something about the risk
that they all take
to do this and when push comes to shove
they will put themselves out there to
help each other for no other reason
than they get it they're one of the same
i will promise you that every single
member of that crew
that day went home with a feeling of
fulfillment
i promise you that every single person
on that crew that day
felt more good in their hearts and in
their jobs then
the richest days they've ever pulled in
my question is is what are you doing to
help the person next to you
don't you want to wake up and go to work
for the only reason that you can do
something good for someone else
wouldn't you want them to do that for
you rule number 14
learn from creative people i'm a lover
of creative people
um and so any sort of expression of
of of how you see the world in with
different terminology is fascinating to
me
and so even though i myself i'm a
photographer um
so i have that visual aspect i'm a huge
fan of modern dance and spend a lot of
time
sort of with dancers and in the dance
world and have you know
tried my hand at choreography just to
see you know
uh i'm not good but it i i like the idea
of trying it
you know um and uh and so
for me it's about perspective which is
when i when when you hang out with
dancers and you you know you sort of
learn to dance a little bit or you learn
to choreograph a little bit or you learn
to paint a little bit you know
i'm not a painter but i painted a
painting recently you know
um you know if you if you unders it's
like chaos theory
you know everything's connected right
you know it's like we we conveniently
divide up our lives like here's my
personal life here's my professional
life i'm
you know here's my social life i'm
looking to find balance it's just you
you know and all the same things apply
and so if you're if you're good here you
can apply what you learn here to there
you know and so when you when you learn
how things interconnect and
and people interconnect and how human
relationships work and presence
i mean you want to learn about presence
take a dance class you learn all about
how to present yourself and be forwards
you know take an acting class learn how
to you know present your speech people
say simon how'd you learn this is like
i'm exposed to all of this um so the
tools i've learned have just
mainly been different perspectives on
how other people use their creative
talents to see the world and if i can
get
little pieces of those they they help me
in many many different ways
rule number 15 know your destination
imagine we're standing
in a big empty room right and we're
standing in one corner and i give you a
simple instruction
i want you to go to that corner in a
straight line
right off you go no big deal right
without telling you
i slip a chair in front of you what do
you do
you go around the chair now you just
disobeyed what i told you to do i told
you to go to that corner straight line
but this is the amazing things about
human beings which is when we're given a
clear destination
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities
to overcome obstacles to get to the
destination in other words the
destination is more important than the
root
right we're flexible about the route
we're obsessed with the destination
reset we're standing in the corner
together and i give you a simple
instruction
go somewhere in this room in a straight
line and you say to me where do you want
me to go i'm like i don't know
you're smart figure it out go in a
straight line and so you pick a point
and you start walking
and without telling you i put a chair in
front of you and what do you do you come
to a grinding halt
and i say what did you stop for you go
will you put a chair in front of me
or you'll make a sudden turn and go in
another direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle
the difference is when you have a clear
set at a clear destination the obstacles
become
easy to overcome when you don't have a
clear destination you keep coming to a
grinding halt and what we do in our
companies
is we're counting the steps we're taking
along the route but we're never looking
at the destination
right so company says made a million
dollars this year we were only planning
on making eight hundred thousand like we
took ten steps we're only planning on
taking eight
where are you going no clue right
we count the steps and so the point is
is that people wanna feel that the
effort that they're exerting actually
are moving somewhere and so successful
measurement successful recognition is
not just for the steps you take
it's not just for the effort it's that
the effort you exerted moved us
closer to where we're trying to get to
and that get to should be some crazy
ideal
my ideal is to live in a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning
you know inspired to go to work and
fulfilled by the work that they do and
the
the couple of measurements that i use
are if the book is selling and i by the
way people ask me how many have you sold
i have no clue
i've never asked the publisher because i
don't care i really don't care how many
i've sold
what i care about is the amazon rankings
and that those are going
steady or up and not plummeting because
that means
other people right because i don't have
a publicist i don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose i didn't hire one of
those companies
to sell the book for me and the reason
is is because i'm not interested in book
sales
i'm interested in the spreading of an
idea and so i just use that as a metric
to help me understand
am i sort of marching in the because the
more i preach
is it resonating you know and so you
have a couple of these
imperfect measurements that help you
understand are you going along the way
so it's not just great effort look what
you achieved
because that's what we're doing now
right our goal is to increase top line
revenues by 50 million dollars
for what reason right which is we have
to know the destination
and then we say amazing
you took us that much closer and if we
go to the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle
if we hadn't gone to the right we would
have been stuck forever
thank you you know it's not always
straight lines
it's not always straight lines but it's
it's in one direction she's pulling the
cane out
rule number 16 be open to the unknown
rarely are we instant experts you may
have a particular gift
or um affinity towards something but you
still get better
you know people would pay me high
compliments when i started speaking
and then people who've seen me a year or
two later say that i'm even better and i
feel it
uh why is that because you you you learn
more you know i think that hubris is
dangerous i think to think that you're
an expert in anything
is a is a foolish pursuit um you're
never
you're never as good as you could be
there's always room for improvement
there's always room to get better you
don't that doesn't mean you have to
listen to all the advice
just you know not necessarily does
everybody know best
but but to believe that you can be
better
and to believe that you can offer more
um is a constant pursuit
um you know i used to think being a
public speaker meant being poised and
presenting in a way that was compelling
and speaking at the right pace and
that's
that's a part of it um but
but i um have been taking more risks
lately doing things that are
very unstructured and very uncomfortable
and i will now do like if i have an hour
to speak i'd rather speak for 20 minutes
and do 40 minutes worth of questions
and who knows how that's gonna go and
that to me is the best
and so i'm a better speaker because now
i'm way more open to the unknown
where a few years ago that that would
have scared me
rule number 17 have balance dopamine
is the feeling uh that you've found
something you're looking for or that you
accomplish something you set out to
accomplish
so you know that feeling you get when
you cross something off your to-do list
that's dopamine feels awesome you know
when you when you have a goal to hit and
you achieve that goal you're like
yes you feel like you've won something
right that's dopamine
the whole purpose of dopamine is to make
sure that we get stuff done right
um the historical reason for dopamine
we would never eat if we only waited to
get until we got hungry because there's
no guarantee that we would find food
so dopamine exists to help us go looking
for food we get dopamine when we eat
which is one of the reasons we like
eating
and so when you see something that
reminds you of something that feels good
we want to
do the behavior that helps us get that
feeling right so let's say you're out
there going for a walk and you see
an apple tree in the distance you get a
small hit of dopamine
and then what it does is it focuses us
on our goals and now we start walking
towards the apple tree and as the apple
tree
starts to get a little bigger we feel
like we're making progress you get
another little shot of dopamine
and another little shot of dopamine
until you get to the tree and you're
like yes
okay this is why we're told you must
write down your goals
your goals must be tangible there's a
there's a biological reason for that we
we're
very very visually oriented animals you
have to be able to see
the goal for it to biologically stay
focused
right if you don't write down your goals
if you can't see your goals
it's very hard to get motivated to get
inspired
for example think about corporate
visions right a corporate vision is have
to be something we can
see right that's why it's called a
vision
you can see it right to be the biggest
most respected
to be the fastest growing are not
visions they're nothing
right what does that even look like
respected by whom your mother
yourself your friends your shareholders
who knows what's the metric
done oh it's amorphous doesn't motivate
us
just like i can't tell you you will get
a bonus if you achieve
more you're going gonna ask me how much
more
i'm gonna say more doesn't work
you need a tangible goal you need a
tangible goal right here's a great
vision
martin luther king i have a dream that
one day
little black children and little white
children will play on the playground
together and hold hands together we can
imagine that
we can set our sights on that and every
time we achieve a goal and achieve a
metric
and achieve a milestone that makes us
feel like we're making progress to the
go the vision we can see we keep going
and going and going until we achieve
something remarkable
you have to be able to see it dopamine
like i said dopamine is the feeling you
get when you set out to find something
you're looking for as well talked about
the to-do list
i came home from a trip just a couple
days ago and i had a bunch of errands to
run and i wrote down a little list of
things i had to do
and off i went right and as i was
walking past
i think it was the dry cleaners i don't
remember i was walking past something
i remembered oh i have to do that and i
hadn't written it down on my i hadn't
written down on my to-do list
so i went in and finished what i needed
to do and then when i came out
i then wrote it on my to-do list and
then crossed it out
because i wanted the dopamine feels good
dopamine comes with a warning dopamine
is
highly highly highly
addictive here are some other things
that
release dopamine alcohol nicotine
gambling your cell phone
oh you think i'm joking okay we've all
been told that uh
you know if you wake up in the morning
and you crave a drink you might be an
alcoholic
well if you wake up in the morning the
first thing you do is check your phone
before you even get out of bed
you might be an addict if you walk from
room to room in your own apartment
holding your telephone
you might be an addict when you're
driving in your car
and you get a text and your phone goes
beep we
we hate email true we love the beep the
buzz the ding oh
right you'll be there in 10 minutes and
yet you have to look at it
right now you might be an addict and
even if you read it and it says
are you free for dinner next thursday
and you have to reply immediately you
can't wait to 10 minutes
you might be an addict and for all you
gen y's out there who like to think that
you're better at multitasking but you
grew up with the technology
then why do you keep crashing your cars
when you're texting
you're not you're not better at
multitasking you're better at getting
distracted
in fact if you look at the statistics
add and adhd
have diagnoses of add and adhd have
risen
66 percent in the past 10 years okay add
an adhd
is a frontal lobe disorder right are you
telling me
out of nowhere 66 of our youth has the
frontal lobe problem
where did that come from no it's a
misdiagnosis
right what what are the what are the
symptoms of a dopamine addiction to
technology
distractibility inability to uh to get
things done
easily easily distracted you know
shortness of attention
it's all the same thing so we
misdiagnose things it's this
it's the addictive quality of dopamine
we can also get addicted to performance
in our companies when all they do is
give us numbers to hit numbers to hit
numbers to hit and a bonus you get and a
bonus you get and a bonus you get
all they're doing is feeding us with
dopamine and we can't help ourselves all
we do is want more
more more it's no surprise that the
banks destroyed the economy
because one of the things we know about
dopamine addict is they will do anything
to get another hit sometimes at the
sacrifice of their own resources and
their relationships ask any alcoholic
gambling addict
or or drug addict ask them how their
relationships are doing and if they've
squandered any of their resources
it's an addiction dopamine is dangerous
if it is unbalanced it is hugely helpful
when in a comfortable and balanced
system but when unbalanced
it's dangerous and it's destructive rule
number 18
turn followers into leaders there's a
brilliant leader by the name of david
who wrote a book called turn the ship
around and he had an experience as a
submarine captain on the uss santa fe
where he realized that as much as he
knew about
submarining you know he'd been a
submariner his whole career
that put on this new submarine he
learned the hard way that he actually
didn't know how the submarine worked he
he he made an order that nobody knew how
to do it because there was
that didn't exist on that sub and so he
realized he had no choice but to trust
his people
and he went through this transformation
as a leader of telling everybody what to
do
to allowing people to tell him what
should be done
and i've learned a lot from him and i
highly recommend his book
and uh and i i've really learned that
which is you know
at the top of the organization as david
says
the people have all the authority the
leaders have all the authority but at
the bottom they have all the context
right and so you can't just push all the
context up you have to push the
authority down um
and so the responsibility of leadership
is to train people make sure that they
have the skill set
help build their confidence that that
they have the confidence to do what
needs to be done
they have to have competence and
confidence right and
that's that's your job that's the only
job of the leader makes it's like
like a parent make sure they have
competence and confidence you know make
sure your kids get schooling and make
sure that they believe in themselves
and then leave them you know and so i've
i've done the same thing instead of sort
of showing people how i would do it
i want them to learn how it's done you
know and
feel good about themselves and then just
however they do it is how they do it
yeah you know
um and the result is remarkable people
feel better about coming to work they
feel like they have something to
contribute they feel more valuable
as opposed to just being told this is
how i would do it or i'm going to do it
this way
or do it my way so yeah
completely changing my understanding of
my job
as more like a parent than a
manager has had remarkable impact
rule number 19 set unrealistic goals
it's easy to pull things back it's very
hard to ramp things up
and i'd rather start with something
that's too big and pull it back into
reality
then start with something that's so easy
that you can't really get it
up for example you know
don't set your goals realistically set
them entirely unrealistically
i mean shoot for 80 and be disappointed
when you hit 70
as opposed to shooting for 20 in being
ecstatic when you hit 21. we beat our
goal
yeah but it was a low goal you know i
think
i think to be frustrated and achieving
something
rather than ecstatic and and achieving
less
is a better way to live not to mention
you achieve more
um so uh i'm a great believer in that
the greater good
like those things are like so big
they're ridiculous i mean like
you know my goal is 100 year goal is
called world peace
you know so daunting
you know but that's the idea if i fail
uh
and i certainly won't achieve it in my
lifetime i like to think that what i'll
contribute towards that
ridiculous idealistic nonsense goal um
will be more than if i say if i can just
be happy by myself
in my little house you know right i mean
that's nice and all but
that's good i like the idea of
contributing to your neighbor as well
rule number 20
take action you speak to businesses and
companies and
leadership teams and employees and stuff
uh without mentioning names i don't want
to put you on the spot but
have you gone and talked to a company
that's been in trouble
and then spoken to their team and then
checked in on them
after you've spoken to their leadership
team and what did that look like
did you notice a noticeable change did
they come to you and tell you that
this has helped our organization out and
our culture is
much improved because of it you mean
does my
work
i mean sure
here's the problem with my stuff you got
to do it
and i am not i'm not anybody's like
you know mom or dad i'm not going to do
it for you
and i have a very lazy fair approach i
once had a
i once had a client this was a bunch of
years ago
that said what guarantee do i have that
your stuff will work
to which my answer was none
like i i'm giving you a tool
you can it's like a hammer you can use
it broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool you can use it for marketing
you can use it to
completely revitalize your entire
culture and even though i'm going to
sell you the most
beautiful hammer i'm not going to
guarantee the structural integrity of
the house
right it's your business you want to
ignore all my stuff
ignore it i don't care it's your and if
your business collapses you know what
happens to me
nothing like i don't mean to be
cold about it like of course i want the
people i work with to do well but it's
not mine it's theirs and i take no
emotional responsibility
for the decisions they make so yes there
are many people that i've had the
pleasure of working with some who worked
for dysfunctional organizations that
went on the
hard journey of completely changing the
way they lead
and completely revitalizing their
culture and it has great success
it's not because of me it's because of
them right at the same time there are
many people who came in like what an
amazing speech and did nothing
you know thanks that was great you know
and i don't
it's of course it's going to fail you
know so
i i think that we we have too much
especially in the consulting world or
the
design world everybody's so
paternalistic
about it and designers are famous for
this right they get so
personally offended when the client
chooses the wrong
thing oh there's such idiots don't they
know we're trying to help them or who
cares
like it's their freaking business right
that's what you find
i've i've had that instead of arguing
with somebody for them to make the right
choice
which because we genuinely want to help
them what i have found is if you push
the accountability until because when we
argue we're taking accountability
this is better this will help you
we're taking responsibility
accountability but if we say look
we've been doing this a bunch of years
we know more about design than you do
i'm telling you for every reason that i
can outline for you
why this will help you more but if you
don't want to do it
that's fine it's your business do what
you want the minute you switch the
accountability and put it all on them
amazingly they're much more open to your
opinion
because now they're responsible rule
number 21 believe
biggest risk you've ever taken um
i completely changed the course of my
life and career when i discovered this
thing called the why i abandoned what i
was doing and said i want to do that and
people thought i was crazy they thought
i went out of business but i was so
i believed in it so much i i threw
caution into the wind
i think why has been the key my whole
life to worldwide
so it's a little kid question that we
grow out of for some reason rule number
22
develop mentorships here's what i've
learned about mentorship
um mentorship is not something you ask
somebody to do
like will you be my friend it doesn't
work like that um
when you find somebody you get along
with you share values you share beliefs
you spend time with them you get to know
them you develop trust you take
uh you're vulnerable with them you open
up to them and you discover that you
become friends it's what happens
you start off as simply acquaintances um
in in my experience mentorship is
exactly the same
there were people who were much more
experienced than me who had
wisdom that i didn't have and i when i
would call them
they would take my calls and when when i
would ask them questions
they would always take the time to give
me answers and
over the course of time they became my
mentors like they became my friends
and i remember one time i was with one
of my mentors ron bruder
an amazing guy and i was leaving his
house and i put my arm around him i said
you know i'm glad you're my mentor
and he looked at me and he said i'm glad
you're mine and it caught me completely
off guard and true mentorship like true
friendship is not a one-way street
it's not about one person only giving
advice to the other both people are
showing
up to give and both people are showing
up uh to learn
um but you can't ask someone to be your
mentor especially someone who's a total
stranger knock on their door
and say will you be my mentor if they
don't know you you've never met them
it's like friendship
you cultivate a relationship and if that
person is always there for you
and wants to see you thrive and succeed
and believes in you
then perhaps they will become your
mentor like making a friend
rule number 23 put your why into action
discovering your why is just the
beginning in order to enjoy all the
benefits of having a clearly articulated
why
you'll need to have the courage and
discipline to use it
like thomas edison said vision with that
execution is hallucination
there is an ideal order for implementing
your why though
sometimes reality does get in the way
and it all starts
with you our natural tendency is to
start with the tangible
we define our value by what we do so it
takes
practice to start with why like riding a
bicycle at first we're unsure
unsteady we're in our heads thinking
about all the things we need to do
pedal fast keep enough speed so we don't
fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over even scrape our knees
but we get back on the bike and try
again and eventually
it becomes natural starting with why is
no different
at first it feels awkward it may not
even work but with practice it will
become
so natural that you won't even be able
to imagine a time when you couldn't
do it just like riding a bicycle
in time your why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions and choices
you make
it becomes a tool to help you find a job
or seize an opportunity
in which you're more likely to succeed
it removes a lot of the guessing
here's a metaphor to show you what i
mean it's called
the celery test we're constantly asking
people for their advice on what to do or
how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need m ms we've done so well with m
m's you've got to use m
ms somebody else says to us rice milk in
this economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us kitkats you have
to use kitkats
and somebody else says to you it's all
about celery
we go to the supermarket with all this
good advice from all these smart people
with brilliant case studies
and we buy everything we buy kit kats
and m ms celery and rice milk
there's a lot of time we spend at the
supermarket and a lot of money we spend
at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout lane
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands
and no one can see what we believe
because we bought
everything but let's imagine we know our
why
let's imagine our why is to always be
healthy and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people
this time we only buy celery and we only
buy rice milk they're the only two that
makes sense
we spend less time and less money at the
supermarket and when we're standing
there in line with only celery and only
rice milk
now people can see what we believe
somebody walking past can say hey i can
see that you're healthy so am i
you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend
simply by saying and doing the things
that you believe and the best part
is it's scalable as soon as i said the
why
you knew exactly which products we were
going to buy
this means the more you can articulate
your why the more
others will know what you stand for and
will be able to help you make the right
decisions
from now on you will work to ensure
everything you do is a good fit
if you do too many things that aren't a
good fit you'll feel uncomfortable
and people will feel that you're being
inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why your ability to stand out
find support and work to all your
natural
strengths will flourish with practice
you will learn to trust your why
you will eventually start to see your
job and the things you do as ways to
breathe life
into your cause and the better you get
at it the more you will feel
that your life and everything you do has
purpose
the best way to implement your why is to
work at it slowly
you don't have to do all the tips we
suggest what is important is that you
pick
up to three and commit to practicing and
using them
now rule number 24 be courageous
what do good leaders have in common um
they
have the courage to do the right thing
um
they're people of high character and
high integrity
um but for me the big one is courage
it's it's very hard to be a leader it's
hard to speak truth to power very often
you might be the one that gets in
trouble or lose your job
it's hard to do the right thing it's
much easier to do
the expedient thing and um
and it's also a huge undertaking to be a
leader every every moment of every day
it's kind of like being a parent
rule number 25 interpret nervousness as
excitement
i was watching the olympics this last
summer olympics and
i was amazed at how bad the questions
were that the reporters would ask
all the athletes and almost always they
asked the same question
whether they were about to compete or
after they competed
were you nervous right and
to a t all the athletes went no
right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean what
what happens when you're nervous right
your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that as i'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes
have learned to interpret the stimuli
that the rest of us would say as
nervous as excited they all say the same
thing no i'm not nervous
i'm excited and so i've actually
practiced it
just to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement
yeah you know and so where when you used
to speak in front of a large audience
and somebody would say how do you feel i
should say
a little nervous now when somebody says
how do you feel i'm like
really excited actually and it it came
from just sort of telling myself
no no this is excitement and it becomes
a little bit automatic later on
um but it's kind of a remarkable thing
to deal with pressure by interpreting
what your body is
experiencing as excitement rather than
nerves
and it's really kind of effective it
makes you want to rush forward rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience
rule number 26 have grand visions
vision here's the here's a thing that's
always boggled my
mind right why is it on balance on
balance not always but on balance why is
it that small companies tend to be more
innovative than big companies
right small companies that are
under-resourced can't
necessarily get the best and brightest
they're going to go out of business
any day and yet there's they come with
brilliant ideas and big companies full
of resources full of amazing people
by the little companies that come up
with the good ideas that's
usually how big companies innovate they
buy the smaller ones right
why is that why is it that the most
resource companies
tend not and i think it's a question of
reality and what i mean by that is
small companies their vision
is is more distant than their grasp
right they have delusions of grandeur
we're going to change the world
change industries reinvent this reinvent
that we have no money and no people but
so what
my point is is the grasp is shorter than
the vision
and i think what happens is as companies
get bigger and bigger and bigger with
more and more resources
what they start to do is one of two
things either
their gr their visions become well
within their grasp and they don't
readjust the vision or they actually
bring the vision back to put within
their grasps
right make things very achievable
difficult but achievable
for vision to truly be vision it should
feel unachievable when a small business
gets together and says here's our vision
everybody goes like this
how are we going to do that in big
business we see here's a vision where he
goes
all right yeah no got it we'll do a back
plan
and i i firmly believe that innovation
is born out of the struggle innovation
is born out of the the resourcefulness
that you're forced to figure out
because literally the vision is way
beyond your grasp
regardless of how many resources you
have it should always
feel overwhelming and impossible take a
group of people with tons of resources
to give them a vision they're going to
go
okay rule number 27 serve others
so how do you define success i think
success is is um is seeing those around
you
work to their natural best and creating
momentum
for a vision towards a vision that will
last beyond yourself
so a guy is driving a bus for
20 years he's got to retire he's on
madison avenue in new york
packed every day is people getting on
that bus and getting off
he has two kids wife lives in queens
he might call himself successful another
guy might be vice president of that
company
who would call himself unsuccessful so
is success what you make of it
so it's so this success is defined it's
success is a feeling
it's not it's not a series of check
marks and goals i think people define
success as as finish lines you know
they well i ran a marathon i'm
successful the question is a why did you
run the marathon and what happens after
you've completed the marathon do you
just keep running marathons what happens
if you break your leg and you can no
longer run marathons
you know we set a lot of people set um
financial goals i'm successful when i
make my first million
ah okay now i have to make my second
million it's success is a feeling
and and it's the feeling of contribution
so your bus driver in queens if he has
decided
that his job as a bus driver is to
ensure that everyone who gets on his bus
feels better about themselves because
they got on his bus and not another bus
and so he greets them with a smile he
says good morning he says goodbye
that people will remember that that that
uh
that ride that they took with him versus
the this vice president of the company
who's made it about himself
and his financial goals he's the one
who's unhappy
as opposed to seeing those around him
succeed and those around him go home
with a love of their their day you know
because they come to work in his company
every day
so i i still believe success and good
leadership are about service to others
rule number 28 learn to communicate your
why
what you'll find is that that um the
better you are at communicating your why
um people will want to work for you
regardless of the opportunity that you
afford them like they want to be a part
of it yeah
we do a little thing which we've been
doing for years and years and years
called a give and take whenever there's
any kind of relationship whether it's a
an outside partnership or even somebody
who joins our team
we do something called a give and take
where we want somebody to be selfish and
selfless
within the relationship so not give and
get but give and take
so we'll ask them what is it that you
have to give to us
that you have that you think that we
need right and they'll tell us and then
we'll say great
what is it that you selfishly want from
us and we want them to tell us what they
can get from us
and when those when those things match
you have a balanced relationship because
so for example i've had it with people
you know they'll tell me what they what
they have to offer and that's awesome
because that's what i want
and then they'll say what they have what
they want to take and they go oh i want
to work with the
smart people i'm like plenty of smart
people what is it you want to take from
me they're like oh i want to help build
something wonderful
do that anywhere what do you want to
take selfishly from me that you can get
nowhere else and if they can't answer
the question
i won't engage in a relationship and the
reason is because in time
the relationship is unbalanced they're
going to be giving but they're not
taking and i don't even know how to give
them what they want then they'll
complain they're not making enough money
or
because it's not balanced that's right
rule number 29 play the infinite game
the game of business is
an infinite game right it obeys all the
rules
um there are known and unknown players
you don't know
all the competitors necessarily in one
industry to another
the rules are changeable we haven't all
agreed what the rules are
and there is no winning the game of
business
right the game just perpetuates in fact
the game of business has existed
longer than every single company on the
planet today and it will outlast
every single commodore company on the
planet today if you look at the dow
index
of 30 something odd companies that make
up the dow index something like 70 or 80
of those companies are 35 years or
younger
right so it gets me thinking if you
listen
to the language that companies use
they don't know what game they're in
they talk about being number one
talk about beating their competition
based on what
agreed upon criteria based on what
agreed upon time frame
is it market share is it profits is it
revenues
square footage number of employees over
what one month
five months six months a year five years
ten years the life of the company
i haven't agreed to those rules and so
companies can arbitrarily declare
themselves number one in anything they
want
if they set the standards and the time
frames and the only reason we do these
things on annualized basis we tend to
we tend to compare ourselves to other
organizations annually
is only because we pay taxes annually if
we pay taxes every 18 months that would
be sort of the standard
but again we still haven't agreed what
the metrics are to be number one
that means the companies that are
playing the infinite game
are playing against most of the others
who are playing the finite game means
those finite companies find themselves
in quagmire almost every single
bankruptcy not almost every every single
bankruptcy
is a company that's run out of the will
or the resources to play they drop out
of the game
the game will persist another company
will fill their space it's not like
it's not like the business stops or the
industry ends
and the companies that are playing the
infinite game will frustrate
those finite players which i absolutely
adore
so i spoke at an education summit for
microsoft i also spoke at an education
summit for apple
now i would say about 70 to 80 of the
executives at microsoft spent about 70
to 80
of their powerpoints
talking about how to beat apple
at the apple summit a hundred percent of
the executives spent a hundred percent
of their presentations talking about how
to help teachers teach and how to help
students learn
one was obsessed with their journey with
their vision with their cause
the other one was obsessed with their
competition guess who's stuck in
quagmire
guess who's frustrated by their
competition
rule number 30 tell great stories so
i'll tell you
another story it's a personal story
it's not one that i share very often and
it profoundly changed
the course of my life
in august of 2011
i had the opportunity to visit
afghanistan
with the united states air force i had
done some work with the mobility forces
these the people that fly the tankers
and the cargo planes and air force one
all the big planes and the general said
to me
simon you've gotten to know us quite
well it would mean a lot to me
if you would go to either iraq or
afghanistan
to see our men and women perform their
mission
would you be willing to go so i said yes
they picked afghanistan now i didn't
tell my parents where i was going
because i didn't want them to worry i
told them i was going
away with the air force true i told them
i was going
to be out of touch for a while because i
was going to be on a lot of planes
true i told them i was going to germany
true i just didn't tell them from
germany i was going to afghanistan
i had no responsibility i was simply
going as an observer
i had two officers who were assigned to
be my escorts
and we met basically for the first time
uh at penn station in philadelphia
where we drove to dover air force base
where we would leave for germany we took
a big c5 cargo plane
in germany we changed planes and we got
on a kc-135 tanker
built in 1956.
i was on a plane built in 1956
where we flew to bagram we landed in the
middle
of the night we touched down
and the big door in the side of the
plane had opened but we hadn't gotten
off the plane yet we'd been on the
we'd been on the ground for maybe 10
minutes and the base came under rocket
attack
three rockets hit a hundred yards off
our nose this is how my
trip began now if you've ever been in a
war zone for those of you
in the room who've ever been in a war
zone you have you know this
you have all the feelings you're
supposed to have you just don't have
them at the right times
weirdly i was incredibly relaxed and
maybe that's because the people i was
with were incredibly
relaxed and i felt safe we revenge the
panic came later
we're eventually given the all clear and
we went to our
housing now the purpose of being in
afghanistan we were going to be in the
country for up to 30 hours and the goal
was to witness an airdrop mission
they're not regularly scheduled so we
had to find out if there was one as soon
as we got there and it turns out there
was one first thing in the morning
so we got about two and a half hours
three hours of sleep
and we went and got on this air drop
mission which was incredible
we sat in the back of a c-17 we flew
about an hour and a half
two hours out to the middle of nowhere
afghanistan the plane dropped down to
about 2000 feet
the back door opened and we sat there
and watched as cargo flew out the back
so we could resupply an army forward
operating base it was an amazing amazing
experience
we then flew back to bagram and the goal
was to come back home
there's no regularly scheduled flight so
we have to sort of find out what flights
we can get on and it's always up to the
discretion of the pilots we found a
flight that was leaving
um shortly after we got back and so we
asked the pilots and they said
absolutely we can join their flight and
we waited and waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited and
eventually we got on the plane we were
all strapped in
literally five minutes from leaving and
the pilot walked up to us and said
i'm sorry we need to bump you guys we
need to make more room for stretchers
it was carrying wounded warriors out of
out of theater and they needed our space
if there's ever a good reason to get
bumped off a plane this was it
so we got off the plane and we went to
look for another flight
and that's when we found out there were
no other flights until tuesday
and this was only saturday i was going
to get stuck in afghanistan for at least
four days maybe longer because we don't
know
what we're going to get on on tuesday
and i have no way of telling my parents
they're not going to hear from me on the
date that i told them that i would get
home
immediately every fiber of my being sank
and i remember becoming completely
panicked
and completely preoccupied with one
thing
my happiness my safety and my comfort
and i didn't care who had to go out of
their way to get me what i wanted
i remember there was a public affairs
officer who said i can get you to
kyrgyzstan but you don't have the right
visa and i looked at him and i said you
get me on that plane
i don't talk to people like that and i
could see myself becoming this person
that i hate it some of us in the room
have worked for somebody
in our careers who wants the next
promotion
and they don't care that they have to
tie our turn our lives upside down so
they can get what they want i was
becoming that person
we went back to our housing and i lay
down on the bed and closed my eyes
my mind was racing i was convinced that
there would be another rocket attack
on the base i was convinced that i was
going to get hit i was convinced that my
parents
were going to find out that i was in
afghanistan when an arm an air force
officer
knocks on the door i was convinced
paranoia
fear everything that you can imagine
swept over me
one of the officers that i was traveling
with said i'm going to see if i can get
us on another flight and he
left the room the other officer thinking
i was asleep
just because my eyes were closed said
well i'm going to go to the gym then
and he walked out and turned off the
lights for me i couldn't sleep
my mind was racing all i wanted to do
was get out of there i regretted saying
yes i regretted being there i didn't
want to be there
i'm in the purpose business i write and
talk about this
sense of why and sense of purpose in our
lives so i started to remind myself
simon
you need a purpose you don't have a
purpose you need a purpose so i started
inventing one
you're here to tell their story it
worked for like a few minutes and then
it would slide back into my
fear and panic again and i realized what
was happening to me
is i was living the equivalent of an
unfulfilled life
compressed into 24 hours i had an
amazing day
i got to see something that most people
will never get to see in their entire
lives except i didn't want to wake up
and do it again the next day
and i think many of us do the same thing
we can
we confuse moments of happiness
with joy and fulfillment we confuse
winning a piece of business getting a
promotion getting an award getting
recognition
doing well on a test with actual deep
fulfillment those experiences are
wonderful
but happiness is fleeting there's not a
single person in this room absolutely
zero
who's walking around with an amazing
sense of accomplishment
for that test that you aced a year ago
that feeling is gone
fulfillment is something entirely
different it's something you carry with
you on a daily
basis whether you're enjoying the day or
not
it's like loving your family you may not
like your family every day but you love
your family every day
one is fleeting the other is lasting
and this is what was happening to me i
realized that i had this amazing day and
i was confusing
happiness and fulfillment and so i gave
up i lay in that bed
paranoid scared and depressed and i
literally
gave up i decided that
if i was going to get stuck here i might
as well make myself useful
and so i decided i was going to
volunteer i would speak anywhere they
wanted me to speak
i would carry boxes and sweep floors all
i wanted to do was
serve some of those amazing people that
i'd met on this trip i wanted to serve
those who served others
and instantly this incredible calm came
over me
i was even excited
this is what fulfillment means it's not
the fleeting joys that we may experience
it's not the accomplishments that we
achieve it's the opportunity to serve
those
who serve others and upon making this
realization i had nothing but joy
and calm and excitement and peace
it was like a movie the timing was
uncanny
upon making this amazing realization the
door
flung open and it was major throch
morton
he said i got us on a flight there's
been a flight that's been redirected but
we have to go now we have to go now if
we don't leave now
they're gonna leave without us where's
matt i said he's at the gym
so we ran to the gym we got him off the
treadmill we ran back
no time to shower he put his uniform
back on we grabbed all our stuff
and we ran out to the flight line when
we got out to the flight line we could
see the plane we were gonna go
we were gonna take home see big c-17 it
was sitting right out there on the
tarmac
and as soon as we got there a security
cordon came down and they wouldn't let
us out to the plane
because somewhere else on base they were
having a fallen soldier ceremony
and out of respect when they have the
fallen soldiers ceremony
everything stops and so so we we sat on
the curb and waited
and i told the guys what i had gone
through in the bed just moments ago
and i cried like a baby and this is one
of the things a lot of people don't
realize about the military
crying is just fine
those guys kept me safe not just
physically they made me feel safe
and i felt totally comfortable telling
them what i was going through and how i
felt
eventually this security cordon came up
and they let us out to the plane
we would be the only three passengers
aboard this plane
other than the crew what i didn't tell
you
is the reason the flight was redirected
is because we would be carrying home the
fallen soldier
for whom they just had the ceremony
the army brought the flag-draped casket
on board all the air force crew stood in
the line at perfect attention
i'm a civilian i put my hand on my heart
i felt kind of stupid
so i stood at attention with the air
force
crew as the army laid the casket in the
middle of the aircraft
they holded a very slow eight-count
salute
they marched off the plane and we
watched them hugging and crying
as they walked away the crew got to work
strapping this precious cargo down
we then had a nine and a half hour
overnight flight back to germany
where i slept right next to this casket
on every other plane i went on we talked
we joked barely a word was
spoken in nearly ten hours on every
other flight i visited the cockpit and
hung out with the crew i didn't visit
the cockpit once
and i'll tell you it was one of the
greatest honors of my life having just
gone through this
incredibly strange experience on the
ground i had the honor of bringing home
somebody who understands service
much deeper than i will ever understand
it
serve those who serve others and you
will live
a life of joy and fulfillment
rule number 31 live your life on purpose
i was uh living in london and attending
law school
i was becoming disillusioned with the
law i happened to be dating a girl
who was in advertising she said you
might like advertising and boom i have a
career in marketing
like i fell into it so many of us fall
into our careers in full entire jobs
and even if we do pursue something we
want to do
sometimes it takes diversions right this
is this is what i mean by living our
lives
by accident which is we largely leave
the direction of our careers and
sometimes even our own happiness to
others our bosses and
you know all of that thing so what it
means to live your life on purpose means
you understand the direction you're
heading
but you remain agnostic as to the root
most people try very very hard to plan
the route in other words what's your
plan people say well first
i'm going to work here for three years
then i'm going to quit and i'm going to
do this
and then for four years and i got the
root plan and the question is where
are you going right and that to me is
what it means to have purpose it means
to have destination
right it's like waking up in the morning
and saying i'm going on holiday somebody
says where are you going said
i'm going on vacation i told you you're
like where are you going vacation
right um and so how are you going to get
there you're like well i'm taking route
95. so you've got the route planned
but you have no destination and you see
this in companies all the time
you know why does your company exist
growth great
why are you growing why do you need to
grow what does growth mean because we're
a company we have to grow
and so they figure out all of these
paths for growth but they don't know
where they're going
i would rather someone wake up in the
morning and say california i'm trying to
get to california
and i don't care what route i take i'm
going to start down route 95 and if i
find a better route i'm going to take it
if there's traffic on route 95
i'm going to take a side road so this is
what happened in my career people kept
telling me
that i was unfocused because i kept
taking side roads i wasn't
unfocused i was going around obstacles
so that's what it means to live a life
of purpose it means i live every single
day of my life trying to get to an end
point
in my case to create a world in which
the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired to
go to work feel safe when they're there
and return home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
that is the destination i'm trying to
reach i don't know how i'm going to get
there
but i'm going to try every path i can to
get there highly highly focused that's
what it means to live a life on purpose
we're often given this advice like do
what you love yeah like what am i
supposed to do
yes like find your passion like thank
you like
great like i don't know what to do
tomorrow for me
passion is the result of something right
so if you work
hard for something you don't believe in
that's called stress and if you work for
so hard for something you do believe in
that's called passion so it's finding
the belief it's finding the cause it's
finding the purpose
and the passion then shows up so it's
not about doing something with passion
and then finding the cause it's finding
the cause
starting with why and then the passion
is what is what results
rule number 32 be a courageous leader
number two it's embarrassing this has to
be on the list courageous leadership
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to sacrifice the short term
in order to advance the long term
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to say no to the money
because it's coming from a dirty source
and rather say yes even though they know
they'll have to tighten the belt
in the short term because it's the right
thing to do
having a just cause if we don't actually
follow the just cause if we don't
actually make decisions through the lens
of the just cause
is just marketing it's just marketing
i'll give you my favorite example
right the ioc the international olympic
committee they have a mission statement
what they believe is their just
cause which is to uh advance the world
make the world a better place through
sport but for the fact that they're all
corrupt
it's a great idea my point is is you
actually have to have leadership that
desperately profoundly believes in the
cause
and will make decisions to advance that
cause they would sooner sacrifice their
own personal interests
to take care of their people they would
never sacrifice their people
to protect their own interests it's
called leadership
it's called leadership we confuse rank
and leadership rank has nothing to do
with leadership
i know many people who sit at the
highest levels of organizations who are
not leaders they have authority and we
do as they tell us because they have
authority over us
but we would not follow them and yet i
know many people who sit at lower ranks
who have no authority and yet they have
made a choice the choice to look after
the person to the left of them
and the choice to look after the person
to the right of them and we would trust
them
and follow them anywhere leadership
is the acceptance of the awesome
responsibility to create an environment
in which people can work at their
natural
best rule number 33 talk about your
beliefs
i went to see a play with a friend of
mine who is an actor
and the play was awful
i mean a train wreck
the script was awful the directing was
awful i mean it was an absolute train
wreck
the question you asked was about
collaboration right should any of those
actors have taken the part
now of course if you're going to take a
part because you need an extra cash
a little extra cash or you want to get a
little extra practice
then you have to do so i think knowing
i'm doing this for the money
or i'm doing this just to keep keep my
my my skills sharp
but i'm under no illusion that this is
something that i connect with but i'm
going to do the best that i can
and then don't lie to yourself you know
the other problem is don't do that too
often because that'll just destroy any
passion that you have for your medium
right and i think and we've talked about
this which is
which is any artist any person but
especially artists
have to know their why you have to know
why you're showing up
in the first place and you have to be
able to talk about it
because if you talk about it things
happen people go
i like you right now you may not get the
part
but you're more likely to find people
who want to work with you even if you're
not the most talented one who auditioned
this is my career by the way right when
i learned to talk about
what i believed i didn't talk about the
things i've done
i didn't talk about the parts i've had
or the shows i've been in or who trained
me
or the schools i went to resume resume
resume
i started i learned to talk about what i
believed
and some people thought it was cheesy
they didn't call me back
good and some people went that's
great and i was not the most talented
not the most experienced
not the best at my field but because
they
stood for or believed in what i stood
for
they wanted to work with me they would
rather work with someone who understood
them who got them
more than somebody who would just take
orders and do exactly what they wanted
regardless of facility rule number 34
get help
there's a paradox being a human being um
unfortunately
at all times every moment of every day
we are both individuals
and members of groups right we are both
responsible for ourselves and our own
happiness and our own joy
but at the same time we're members of
families we're members of churches we're
members of teams we're members of
companies
like we're members of multiple groups
every single day at every moment
and this produces some complications we
have to make decisions
so do we put ourselves first or do we
put the group first and there's a debate
some people say oh you have to take care
of yourself before you can take care of
the group
and some say no no you take care of the
group and that's what helps they will
take care of you and the answer is yes
it's not one or the other it's actually
both simultaneously
it is a challenge but at the end of the
day there's no getting around it
as social animals our success our
happiness our joy
our ability to get anything done
requires help
and those who embrace the fact that they
cannot do everything alone
that they need the support and love and
it doesn't mean somebody who's
physically helping you live something
sometimes it might be someone who just
believes in you these things are
essential and there's just no getting
around it
rule number 35 have a worthy rival
the next part is a worthy rival
now i said before that the only true
competitor in an
uh an infinite game is yourself this is
true what your competition does
is it helps reveal to you your
weaknesses
admire the others in your organization
not to beat them there's no such thing
not to be number one there's no such
thing but if somebody else is better
than you at something
that means you have to go work harder
yourself it's like running in a race
if you're driven to be number one if
you're driven to make the most money if
you're driven to
show up in some arbitrary ranking that
you don't even have a say in
that's like tripping the the next runner
you will win the race
but you're still a slow runner rather
fall behind this year and then you work
and work and work because ultimately the
goal is not to be number one this year
the goal is to create an organization
that will outlast every single one of
you
this is about building strong
foundations this is about
looking long-term in the short term
money is simply fuel to
to to make the car go
we don't own cars to buy more fuel
we own cars to go somewhere it's the
same thing in an organization your
organization exists to advance
something the money is simply there to
make a go and i
fear that what has happened in the
university system is similar to what i'm
seeing
in business it's similar to what i'm
seeing in politics
it's similar to what i'm seeing in
hospitals
which is an over uh the sense of
excessive pressure
to bring money in at the expense of
something else
there's an excessive amount of
short-termism and
massive amounts of rationalizing this is
just the game
we just have to do it if we don't
somebody else will
the obsession with getting grants
meaning you're hiring people who are
more likely to help you get a grant
even though they're teaching things that
we don't necessarily even need or want
that's called short-termism rule number
36 focus
on positive thinking these people always
complain that
why can't i ever get that and these
people complain i can never get a job
you're going to be stressed no matter
what focus on the thing that you're
getting because that's the choice you
made right
much rather you focus the thing you you
you're you're pursuing rather than the
thing you're missing
and so this idea of affirmative thinking
positive thinking
is essential for all people but i think
it's especially essential for artists
and there's a very very simple
biological reason
for it which is the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative it is
incapable
yes it's true i'll give you an example
okay no no i'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
i'll prove it i'll prove it okay the
human brain cannot comprehend the
negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something
right and so what happens is we very
often reinforce
things when we put things in the
negative
right i can't get apart i can't get
apart
i can't get apart right or um
i can't do this versus i'm going to keep
doing this
i'm going to keep doing this i'm going
to keep doing this
right um and and it's such a huge thing
to convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well
we're supposed to say instead of saying
to children don't eat on the couch we're
supposed to say
eat at the table right we tell people
what we want them to do
not what we don't want to do pilots know
this right
it is well known in the pilot community
that when you tell a pilot don't hit the
obstacle they'll hit the obstacle
because what they're doing is focusing
on the obstacle rule number 37
do something new i went to this event
and just by share
coincidence at the dinner i'm sitting
next to dawn and sam goldwurm who run
this company called 1229
and that's exactly what they do dawn is
a master nose
who used to work for cody the perfume
company so you produce all the famous
perfumes that we all know
and they want to start their own company
where they design
custom sense for brands but the way to
think about this is
beyond sort of verbena and patchouli the
way dawn explained it to me
is there are seven notes on the musical
scale
and you can play chopsticks or you can
play a beethoven symphony it's the same
seven notes it's what you do with it and
she does the same thing
with smell which is you can have simple
smells or you can have highly complex
ornate orchestras uh
symphonies rather and so they sat down
with me and took me through
a fantastic process and they produced
the smell
of optimism and it's the most beautiful
thing
and the idea was born out of the fact
that i'm sitting next to this event
and i turned them and said have you ever
sent it a book has that ever been done
before
and they said no it's never been done i
said well we should really do that
and so of course my publisher was not
excited to hear about that but
but it's the first time that i know that
a book has ever been centered in this
way
so it is a scented book the smell of
optimism
uh is what you start with and it sets
you on your journey to enjoy the rest of
the book
rule number 38 have a just cause
i'll ask you a very simple question why
does your organization
exist we don't need you
clearly there's plenty of competition
clearly people have plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do
a reasonably good job they might even be
better than you in some areas
so why do you exist providing education
is
table stakes everybody here does that
you can't rely on that that's why the
industry exists
not why your organization exists that's
like when i talk to healthcare companies
and say
why does your organization exist and
they say to help people be more healthy
like no kidding thank you but i know
that the culture of one organization
is different than the culture of another
organization there are cultural norms
that wrap around the sense of purpose
cause or belief great organizations
understand their just cause a cause
so just that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause
sacrifice comes in many forms it might
mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas
turning down a better job that offers me
more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite examples of a just
cause is the declaration of independence
our founding fathers declared literally
wrote down
they declared why we needed our own
country
all men are created equal endowed with
these unalienable rights amongst which
include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
they were never against
britain the whole point is not to be
against something but to stand
for something britain was simply
standing in the way of them advancing
their cause
and though they won independence there
are always finite games within the
infinite game
though they won independence that didn't
mean that they had now provided all men
are equal now the real heavy lifting
began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war
george washington understood how
limiting that was and he realized
that they had to have a broader
definition so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics in his armies and he would
regularly attend mass
to send the right message some time
later
we abolished slavery and the 14th
amendment
some time later we had women's suffrage
sometime later we had civil rights act
some time later we implement gay rights
and you can see that
we are striving to provide this thing
called all men are equal
people are equal and though we will
never actually get there we will die
trying
and the obstacles may always be
different and what a just
cause is it is a vision of the future
that does not yet exist
and you will commit all of your energies
to advance
that vision of the world that you have
and the people you want to attract
both those who work there those who
teach there and both those who come to
learn there
believe in your vision of the future so
much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else
because they want to be around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just
cause is what you stand for otherwise
the only thing i have to judge you on
is superficial things it's like dating
right it's like dating if if somebody
tells me what they stand for who they
are
they're talking about their character
and those are the people we want to
spend
the rest of our lives with if we do not
have any sense of who they are
what they stand for what their purpose
what their cause what their beliefs are
what their values are the only thing we
have to judge them on is how much money
they make
and how good looking they are rule
number 39 stand out from
others i'm a huge modern dance lover
like that's the thing i love
and i don't go to the joyce anymore
because everything that they have on
their stage is good
it's good everything is safe to me
they put things on their stage that
that's good they sell tickets
nothing's bad and nothing's great
it's all good i don't go anymore i go to
bam a lot
i have seen things that have profoundly
changed my view of the world and i have
walked
out of more things at bam
literally i'm like i'm done and my
friend's like you can't i'm like we can
you know i have walked outs out of
so many things at bam and yet i continue
to go and continue to go and i continue
to go because i know what they stand for
that's my preference i'm not saying it's
right or wrong i'm saying that's my
preference
that i would rather take the risk of
walking out
knowing that i might get moved in a way
that i've never experienced before
more than just going to have a nice
night out and see something that i know
is good
right and i think that goes for our
careers as well
you know which is if you choose to be
the kind of artist
that stands for something that you want
to be yourself and bring yourself into
everything that you do you will get
fewer parts
you will the parts you get
will move you in a way that most artists
will not get moved
or you can bend and manipulate yourself
a little bit and
sort of be a little bit more of what
they want
and play their role and even though you
don't really buy into it
it's a part and i want to be an actor i
want to be a performer i'm going to i'm
going to do what they want
you will absolutely get more parts
without a doubt
you will you will can arguably have a
better career but will you be profoundly
moved as an artist
the odds are lower it's not i can't say
never it's just the odds are lower
it's not better or worse it is simply
the decision
on how you choose to manage or lead your
own career
both are acceptable right one means you
get to use your facility a lot
one means you get to work a lot one
means you might be able to do only your
art and actually make a living
one means that you're going to be
meeting a lot of people and the odds are
that you will connect with somebody at
some point
or you choose this route
which is much more difficult and is
fraught with much more risk
and much more struggle but you become
known for the thing that you
are rule number 40 be a problem solver
i think the word entrepreneur is bandied
about too loosely
that not everyone who owns a small
business is an entrepreneur
there are small business owners and
they're entrepreneurs what's an
entrepreneur and you can find
entrepreneurs
in big companies it doesn't mean that
they're small business owners right
i think entrepreneurs are problem
solvers i think rather than risk takers
yeah i think fundamentally there are
plenty of risk takers i think who are
entrepreneurs there's a risk taker of
your small business owner
right you went out to start the business
but they're not the same
i don't think um and entrepreneurs are
those ones who
they're constantly looking to solve
problems and that's where i think they
perceive opportunity or the mischief
that you describe
i don't think it's i don't think
inherently it's a sense of mischief
they're not trying to stir the pot for
the sake of stirring the pot
i think that they see something and
they're like we can make that better or
we can fill that hole
and that's very much the way the famous
entrepreneurs the elon musks and the
richard bransons operate
they see gaps they see things that don't
work as they chose
as did jobs they see things that could
be better they
i mean elon musk was just interviewed by
chris anderson at ted last week
and chris anderson sort of near the end
of the interview it's online
go watch it it's really great um
uh chris anderson asks elon musk
something to the effect of
why why are you doing all these things
like why don't you just stick with tesla
and be done with it like why do all the
other stuff and you look at
and musk you can see this look on his
face and he takes a long time to answer
he actually doesn't understand the
question
he cannot understand why you wouldn't do
that
and he sort of gets emphatic which elon
musk is pretty amazing because he
doesn't get emphatic
um but that's basically what it is he
gets emphatic and says because i want to
live in a world that's better than this
or words to that effect you know where i
am not where the world that we're living
right now makes us unhappy why don't we
want to live in a world that makes us
happy
you know he gets sort of he can't
understand and again it's vision
first and that's why he doesn't
understand why you wouldn't try and
solve problems
rule number 41 don't obsess with
competition
companies obsess about their competitors
which is fine tactically
which is fine for short term but long
term
most companies aren't brought down by
the competition they know about they're
brought down by the competition they
don't know about
some new emerging technology you know do
you think the music business
was paying attention to the computer
business at all of course not they were
paying attention to other music
companies
um you know myspace wasn't
focused on friends facebook they didn't
know facebook existed
but it's facebook that brought them down
or significantly hurt their business
right in other words if you don't even
know who your competitors are
what's the point of fixating and making
all of your business decisions based on
competitors all we're doing is reacting
reacting reacting this is why purpose
matters
it gives us a north star yes we have to
concern ourselves with our competition
from a tactical
and short-term point of view but to make
long-term strategic decisions
based on a competitive set that we don't
even know that's complete based on
technology that we don't even know it's
it's completely fully baked is madness
it's absolutely madness
right so you want to fixate on the on
the
the uh on the path rule number 42
follow your vision not the trends what
do leaders of which there are many
uh gathered here today what do leaders
need to do to understand
the trends in their industry better
because it's very easy to say this is
where this business or this is where
this competition
this market is going it's actually
that's what everyone else is doing so
how can you get ahead of a trend
in the way that steve jobs was able to
look at where the puck is going so trend
data is very dangerous
because all it does is report a trend it
doesn't report if it's positive or
negative and everyone else has got it
and everybody else has got it
so for example you know kids these days
are all using
uh apps to do everything we should make
more apps
but nobody says it's healthy right in
the 1980s you needed to do cocaine to
get through the business day
you know does that that's a trend that's
a trend it's not really true cocaine
usage was up
in the 1980s in businesses it was if you
worked in an investment bank you did
yeah yeah
no i was i
the point is the point is if the point
is it's a trend yeah that doesn't mean
we should invest in it
right so trend data is i think the way
people rush towards a trend
because they think that's where the
market is going is very dangerous
because it's incredibly unstable
information
but you have to as a leader anticipate
where your market is going and make
three or five year plans
and the way you do it is with vision
right so
for some reason somebody keeps telling
me that i unders my publisher said this
to me that i'm good at understanding the
zeitgeist
uh and he's wrong i have no clue
about what people are thinking all i
know is where i want to go
that's it as i said before i have a
vision of a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired to go to work feel safe
when they're there
and return home fulfilled at the end of
the day so i can make certain guesses
and predictions about things i have to
do to get there
rule number 43 be willing to ask for
help
the biggest lesson i learned was thank
goodness i learned it pretty early on
which is and i think a lot of business
owners make this mistake
um which is uh because i was the boss
you know in my own mind yeah um uh
i thought i had to know all the answers
and if i didn't i thought i had to
pretend that i did
and uh that's stupid
um and what i learned is that
just because i may have the the top
position in the hierarchy
i i'm not expected to know everything
and if i pretend to know everything
it diminishes the value of all the great
ideas and the great
intelligence around me and when things
got difficult i would never admit it
right i would just put on a brave face
and show up every day and
um and the the biggest lesson i learned
was to say i don't know i don't
understand or i need help
um at any level about any subject yeah
and
amazingly i was always surrounded by
people who wanted to help or who knew
answers but they never offered to help
or
offer the answers because they didn't
think i needed it because i kept
pretending that i knew it all
right not to mention the fact that
nobody likes a no at all um
so that was huge for me and when i was
willing to ask for help and
accept it when it was offered and and
sort of accept the humility
of the fact that other people know a lot
more about
a lot of things than i know i know one
thing you know and they know lots of
things
um uh that's when things really started
to move because
we were now a team like we were actually
working together rule number 44
focus on the positives i see a lot of
questions here around dealing with a
negative team or dealing with a team
where we feel
people may not have the right intentions
or the right motives how do people work
with that the viewers are asking
yeah it happens um and the answer is
don't worry about it like we can't
obsess
about the ones that are doing something
wrong we obsess about the ones that are
doing something right
instead of criticizing the ones that are
negative we want to build up and
complement the ones that are positive
because when that's the reward structure
which is finding
and identifying and rewarding good
then everybody wants to be rewarded and
recognized and so eventually the
behavior comes in as opposed to
criticizing wrong nobody wants to be
criticized and all it does is it makes
people back away and afraid
so the point is ignore the negativity
and focus on the positivity and start
obsessing about the people that are
doing something
right i learned this lesson the hard way
i wrote a blog
and we had a uh uh somebody write in
with a very aggressive
sort of note to me and sort of saying
i'm a hypocrite and all of this stuff
and my team got together and we
discussed our response and somebody
wrote back and
he rebecca very nicely responds back and
we thought okay how do we react to this
and i eventually got on the phone with
him and tried to talk with him and they
talked him off the shelf and talked
about the you know it was okay
and about six months later i wrote
another blog and he wrote another
and we got together and it occurred to
us we were spending all of this time
with one negative person yeah and we
were ignoring
all of the people who wrote in
compliments and were supporting
our work and so we literally made a
decision that day that when we got
results like that we wouldn't care and
that if we were going to invest any time
of our people it was going to be to say
thank you to the people who were
helping us and helping compliment us and
helping advance the message
and so we don't i personally don't
respond to those at all
anymore ever but i regularly call people
up
to say thank you for helping advance the
cause and it feels nicer
and there's time better spent and we're
not wasting time anyway so
yeah focus on the positive rule number
45 empower individuals
so was steve jobs playing the finite
game because he was crushing the
competition
or was he playing the infinite game
because he just did his own thing
so jobs had a very clear vision
and it was to give the individual the
power to stand up to big brother
he was at his heart a rebel he grew up
in
northern california during the vietnam
war
which was the where the beginning of the
anti-establishment revolution sort of
started
yeah and that was his childhood um and
so
he really he really stood for the
individual standing up to
to to the man and he had a big spiritual
side he was a buddhist at times
yeah and if you look at the decisions he
made he made decisions like this he ran
decisions through his vision
before he got to the interests right so
there's a very famous story of when he
went to xerox park do you know this one
so jobs they just come up the success of
the apple one and the apple ii
it's already a big company he's already
well known it's a it's
he's already the darling of business um
and
uh their next big push is going to be
into a technology they call the lisa
that was their next computer that they
were going to launch
and just as executives do they visit
each other's companies
and jobs and a few of his colleagues
went to visit xerox park
and xerox showed them a new technology
that they had invented
called the graphic user interface right
now remember jobs believed in the
individual standing up to big brother
so the reason they made their computers
beautiful was not arbitrary
it's because if you had them if they
were pretty looking you'd put them in
the living room
if they're ugly you put them in the
basement and you're more likely to use
something that's in the living room than
if it's in the basement
right the reason you make them simple is
because more people can
then use them and so when he saw this
thing called the graphic user interface
he thought this is a better technology
it's a leapfrog
to make it easier for more individuals
to access the power of the personal
computer
than what we have in the lisa so that's
an infinite game because he's thinking
about what's right for the long term
rather than what is competitive and as
they left
dr park job says we have to invest in
this and his
colleagues said we're you're crazy we've
invested millions of dollars
millions of man hours already in the
lisa if we
do this if we invest in this we're going
to blow up our own company
to which jobs replied better we should
blow it up than someone else
that decision became the mac the
macintosh that decision was the
macintosh
of which remember windows is an
interface designed to copy the macintosh
in other words he completely changed the
way computers work to the point where
now any individual
can easily use a computer and
he always made decisions that way he
made decisions
always empowering the individual so he
was asked
a question about the movie industry
cinemas and the decline of cinemas and
he replied that
the the cinemas were making the same
mistake the movie industry was making
the same mistake that the music industry
made
which is the music industry falsely
believed that their customer
was tower records and virgin megastore
and not the person who actually spent
money on buying the album
he says you've confused your customer
with you with your distribution channel
rule number 46 have a trusting team i
was boarding a flight and the scene
played out in front of me
where one of the passengers attempted to
board the plane before
their group number was called um and the
gate agent
uh literally berated him sir step aside
i haven't called your group
please step aside and wait till i call
your group so i spoke up and said
why do you have to talk to us that way
why can't you talk to us like we're
human beings
and she looked me in the eye and said if
i don't follow the rules i could get in
trouble or lose my job
all she revealed to me is that she
doesn't feel safe in her own company
and her leaders do not trust her to do
the job for which he's been trained to
do
and guess who suffers us and the company
the reason we love flying southwest
airlines
is because the company trusts them to do
the job they've been trained to do
and they use discretion we don't trust
people to follow the rules we trust
people to know
when to break them and the problem is in
a fear-based society
people fear for their own jobs more than
common sense
that was a perfectly a perfect scenario
of what happens
when somebody in the company is too
afraid to break the rule
break the policy use discretion find
another way you know
so almost predictable that something
will happen and something will break at
some point
rule number 47 find true joy how would
someone know
if they're doing something for their why
how do you know
oh you can feel it you feel it you ever
had that experience
where um you feel like something's wrong
yeah you know sort of you're like you
make a decision but it makes you
uncomfortable
you're not you're not following through
with your cause or your purpose and you
ever have a decision where everybody's
like you're crazy you're crazy like this
just feels like the most natural normal
thing
i could do i'm not even in doubt here
you know right now the problem with
simply running on gut is it's not
scalable this is the reason we want to
learn our why
learn to articulate and be able to speak
our why so that
others can understand why we're making
the decisions we're making
because the problem is if you only trust
your gut to those around you sometimes
it does appear that we're crazy or
unfocused
and so people leave us and don't help us
because they think we're nuts
the minute we can articulate and speak
that why with clarity that others can
understand
then not only will they have context for
the decisions we're making
but they'll rally to help us and even do
things that we didn't even ask because
they understand
the higher purpose that we're trying to
advance so
you just know it's a terrible answer um
but you can feel it and this is where
joy and fulfillment in our work come
from which is different from happiness
you can win a big client get a promotion
get a raise happy
you know do a good job produce something
great happy
but that feeling dissipates it doesn't
last for
you know it certainly doesn't last for
months or years it might last for days
or weeks
right that that immensely happy feeling
that we all have that big client we won
or that big promotion we got
is now gone joy fulfillment
which doesn't mean that we love every
day but joy and fulfillment comes from
that feeling that every day our work is
contributing to something bigger
and that's that's way more important oh
also at least as important
rule number 48 run your business by your
values
so the infinite game exists up here
finite game exists down here right
the infinite game is includes the why
what i call our purpose cause or belief
it's
the vision of the company it's where
we're going it's something that we will
never practically reach
in our lifetimes or ever but we will die
trying that's
the point right it's different from a
big hairy audacious goal which for all
practical purposes you could reach it
may be difficult but you could
reach it this is an ideal something
it's a vision of the world so my vision
i imagine a world
in which the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspire to
go to work
feel safe when they're there and return
home fulfilled at the end of the day
that is my vision
right we will never practically get
there but we will die trying
the united states was founded with a
document called the declaration of
independence
in which the document stated all men are
created equal
now the united states has not achieved
that and will never achieve that
but it the country is at its best when
we're trying to achieve that civil
rights
women's suffrage gay rights the you know
universal
education universal healthcare etc etc
this is where our values exist
our values are timeless they do not
change every year whenever we have a
strategic offsite and if they do
you have a problem that happens in big
companies
every few years a new ceo comes in and
they have a values thing and they change
and they change and they change no no
your values are your values
right and they're based on your founders
and they exist from patterns
of how you operate when you are
operating at your natural best
when your company is operating at its
natural best when all cylinders are
firing when you're in the flow whatever
euphemism you want to use
there is a pattern that emerges and that
pattern are your values there's a
minimum of three there's no more than
five
if there's more than five there's
usually redundancy you can find overlap
that you can find lowest common
denominators
and they are intractable these things
are inherently intangible
and hard to measure right
which is why they often get brushed
aside it's not that they don't exist
they're just hard to measure
then down here you have the finites what
i call the what it's all the tangible
stuff
right things like our interests exist
down here
because they are tangible they are
inherently easy to see
and easy to measure like products sold
money taken in things like that right
number of clients we have
the way you build an infinite business
is you want to run all decisions
first through your values and your cause
and then
through your interests that's how it
works rule number 49
have infinite goals i've become very
very
interested in the idea of
playing in games that have no finish
lines
right some games have finish lines
right baseball football right um
getting apart is the finish line you
audition
there's a beginning middle and end
there's rehearsal and practice
there's uh uh showing up for the
audition
and you either win or you lose and then
it's over
it's over right that is finite but one's
career
is infinite there's there's no end it's
like
our lives are finite but life is
infinite
people come and people go but life
continues right theater
actors come and actors go but theater
continues it's infinite you don't win
theater
you win a part but what happens once you
get the part
the the finite game is over now you
enter the infinite game you have to be
able to convert
right and the reason this is important
and i've seen this unfortunately so many
times
from a young age all you wanted to do
was get to broadway
and then you get to broadway and then
what you've devoted your entire life to
one finite goal and when you get there
the immediate response is depression
because i
i spent 15 years of my life for this one
thing
and i got it and now i don't know what
to do next
like what a get to broadway again it
doesn't have the same
ambition
it doesn't have the same passion you
know you've devoted you're from
you know you're from fargo north dakota
and that's all you wanted to do is get
out of fargo and make it to broadway and
you made it
right it doesn't have the same kind of
passion and this is because these are
finite goals
there's a lot of studies that have been
done
with athletes who have finite goals
to become the greatest ex in the world
right
so andre agassi was one of these one of
these athletes he wanted to become the
greatest tennis player that ever lived
guess what everyone
in his life he would he would view them
through how do you help me
get to that everything was how does this
help me get to that
everything was a transaction to how do
you help me move to there and then you
know what happens he achieved it he
became the greatest tennis
player in the world and you know what
happened immediately after
depression michael phelps
set out to become the most meddled
olympian in history do you know what
he achieved it you know what happened
immediately after depression
they spend their whole life working for
one goal
though most will never get it the few
that do
don't know what to do next because their
goals were finite
their goals were finite right and so
there are finite components to your
career
but your career should be infinite
so yes of course you have to win the
finite game you have to get the part but
immediately when you get the part
now you convert to infinite and rule
number 50 the last one before very
special bonus clip
is be a courageous leader in military
we're willing to sacrifice ourselves for
the gain of others right but in business
we're willing to sacrifice others for
our own gain
yes how do you build that military
mindset in companies like here or
other companies leadership i mean it's
it's leadership creates an environment
and it's i mean this is what i learned
the the
the whole concept of leadership last and
those lessons that i learned from
spending time
with folks in uniform um it was born out
of my own
experience where i i was going through a
point in my career as my career was
growing
all of a sudden you have new friends
that i didn't have before
and and that's wonderful and then i
learned the hard way
that they weren't my friends they were
playing me they wanted
access or a deal or something right and
i and i i learned it the hard way
and so i retreated i was like i wanted
to be friends with nobody else but the
people i knew way back when which is
also not a good way to live
and yet simultaneously i'm spending time
with tons of folks in the military
who you know in business we have
colleagues and co-workers in the
military of brothers and sisters
and that's a different kind of
relationship and as you know i have
hugged more people in uniform than i've
ever hugged in suits
i've cried with more people in uniform
than i've ever cried with in suits
i've stood in the audience and listened
to officers give talks and i've sat in
the audience and cried
i've never cried with any ceo game gave
a speech ever
right so there's a different nature of
relationship and my original conclusion
was they're better people that the
reason you get a disproportionate amount
of these kinds of
behaviors is because they're better
people and better people
are drawn to a life of service in the
military which is why we find a
disproportionately high number of them
there and the more i started to learn
the more i realized i was completely
wrong
it's the environment it's the
environment and when the leader creates
an environment
in which people feel that someone has my
back they will do extraordinary things
and what i learned is that courage is
not this deep down internal fortitude
right it comes externally it's like a
trapeze artist would never try a brand
new death defying act
unless they had a net the courage didn't
come from
the trapeze artist the courage came from
the net and it's the same
in the military which is especially when
you're in life and death situations when
you're
when you're when you're in theater
people who you don't like you still rely
on to save your life and the reason it
works is because you don't have to look
behind your shoulder
and that mentality and you know better
than anybody
which is when you when you are deployed
into dangerous
places nobody sort of loves deployment
but people have warm feelings
towards deployment which is really
strange and suicides
rarely happen in in combat situations
they usually happen
back home and it's the intensity of the
relationships
that create that warmth and the sort of
weird enjoyment of really bad
uncomfortable and dangerous
circumstances it's because this we're
human beings and human beings as social
animals
feel our safest when we trust each other
and good leaders are capable of
producing that so
great businesses look very much like
well-run military organizations and you
know there's poorly run military
organizations as well
but great businesses look exactly the
same where the leaders
give the glory they distribute authority
they push it down the ranks let people
make decisions if they screw up there's
no risk of getting fired
if the company misses its arbitrary
projections on its arbitrary date we do
not use the people to balance the books
we figure out other ways or we even
invite the people to help solve the
problems
these are the things that produce that
circle of safety that produces the exact
same outcome where people will love each
other
cry for each other sacrifice for each
other you see it in business
plenty but it always boils down
to leadership now i've got a special
bonus gift from simon on how to be
the best version of yourself that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the
three-point landing questions you
watched the video now let's take action
here we go question number one what are
your
infinite goals number two how will you
talk about your beliefs
this week and number three what's a new
way that you could turn your why
into action there's no such thing as
winning business
there's no such thing as uh winning
global politics
and there's definitely no such thing as
winning education
but if we listen to the language of too
many organizations
they don't know the game they're in they
talk about being the best
they talk about being number one they
talk about
beating their competition the problem is
there's no such thing
let me give you a real life example that
sheds some light on what i'm talking
about
i spoke at an education
summit at microsoft i also spoke
at an education summit at apple
at the microsoft summit the vast
majority of the executives spent the
vast majority of their presentations
talking about how to beat apple
at the apple summit a hundred percent of
the executives
spent a hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one was obsessed with where they were
going the other one was obsessed with
their competition
guess which one was in quagmire at the
end of my talk at microsoft they gave me
a gift they gave me the new zune when it
was a thing
this was microsoft's response to the
ipod
and this little piece of technology was
absolutely
incredible it was beautifully designed
the user interface was intuitive and
very simple to use it was
really brilliant i have to say
so at the end of my apple talk i was
sharing a taxi with a very senior apple
executive employee number 54 to be
exact and i decided to stir the pot i
couldn't help myself
i turned him i said you know microsoft
gave me their new zune
and it is so much better than your ipod
touch
to which he said i have no doubt
and the conversation was over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your competitor has the better
product and sometimes you have the
better product
and sometimes you're ahead and sometimes
you're behind
but there's no such thing as best or
first or beating your competition
there's only a head and behind
and the reality of an infinite game is
you're actually
only competing against yourself that the
objective
every single day is how do we become a
better version of our own institution
this year than we were last year how do
we improve the quality of our culture
how do we improve the quality of the way
we uh provide the service that we claim
to be providing
how do we improve ourselves that is the
main point
of being an infinite game because at the
end of the day we don't have the same
metrics as everybody else
and we're not even necessarily playing
to the same ends if you want to learn
how to start with why with simon
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there i don't have a
time in my life
many years ago 10 years ago where i had
lost my passion for what i was doing
i own my own small business